sean bienvenidos al vídeo de derivación
implícita pero antes de empezar a ver la
teoría de la derivación implícita lo que
yo quiero analizar es que es una función
implícita y que es una función explícita
entonces vamos a ver las diferencias
supongamos que yo tengo la función y es
igual a x cuadrada más 2 x más 3 si se
dan cuenta esta es una función explícita
porque el iedt depende de x o dicho de
otra manera para cada valor que me den
ustedes de x yo lo puedo poner en esta
ecuación que voy a obtener un valor de
jr la ye está en términos de x brinca
como resultado para cada valor de x
bueno ahora supongamos que yo tengo en
la ecuación x cuadrada más y cuadrada
esto igual a 100 ahora mi pregunta es
qué pasa aquí si yo les doy un valor de
x bueno si yo que soy un valor de x no
es tan fácil saber el valor de ya
tendríamos que despejar ahí entonces
supongamos por ejemplo que x valga no sé
99 al cuadrado 281 entonces 81 más y
cuadrada sería igual a 100 y si yo restó
81 de los dos lados me quedan
y cuadrada es igual a 19 y ahora pasando
el cuadrado me queda que es igual a más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 19 aunque este
numerito esté un poco raro pero bueno lo
importante de este ejercicio es que aquí
no tengo a despejada a la y por lo tanto
es una función implícita una función
implícita es aquella donde no tengo una
variable despejada de la otra de hecho
si se dan cuenta esto es muy parecido al
lenguaje cotidiano uno puede decir de
manera explícita
no sé sal tengo hambre eso es decirlo de
una manera explícita pero también lo
puede ser una manera implícita diciendo
por ejemplo
oye sal hace mucho que no como y no sé
sería bueno ir por una torta y que nos
viéramos en ese momento no están
diciendo tal cual que tiene hambre lo
están haciendo de una manera implícita
hay que hacer algo de trabajo para
entender que esta persona tiene hambre
pero bueno ese es otro tema y ya me está
dando hambre así que regresemos a la
derivación implícita nosotros hasta el
día de hoy hemos derivado funciones de
manera explícita como ésta
sabemos derivar este tipo de funciones
de hecho podemos hacerlo vamos a hacer
si yo quisiera sacar la derivada con
respecto a x es la tasa de cambio con
respecto a x lo que hay que hacer es
aplicar el operador derivada de ambos
lados de la ecuación es decir voy a
hacer con otro color la derivada con
respecto a x de y es igual a pues la
derivada con respecto a x de lo que está
del otro lado del signo igual x cuadrada
más 12 x + 3 y ahora si yo saco la tasa
de cambio que voy a obtener pues la
derivada de ye con respecto a x es decir
la tasa de cambio en una muy pequeña la
dejo igual la derivada de ella con
respecto a x y del otro lado de la
ecuación derivó con respecto a x
esto es una parábola es muy fácil
derivar lo la derivada de x cuadrada es
2x la derivada de 2x es 2 y la derivada
de 3 se va se anula porque es una
constante y ya está ya aquí tenemos la
derivada de que con respecto a x igual a
2 x + 2 es decir la derivada que siempre
hemos sabido hacer o la derivación
explícita ahora bien la pregunta es cómo
voy a derivar la función que tengo abajo
como hago para derivar una función que
no es explícita es decir es implícita
entonces voy a borrar aquí
ahora si tengo más lugar para trabajar
derivación implícita yo tengo esta
función y quiero sacar su derivada y
bueno la idea es la siguiente voy a
aplicar mi operador derivada a ambas
partes de la ecuación justo como lo
hicimos arriba si a una igualdad yo le
hago una cosa de un lado y de la otra se
mantiene la igualdad entonces la
derivada con respecto a x de quien bueno
primero voy a poner la función que
tenemos aquí es cuadrada más de cuadrada
esta va a ser mi derivada del lado
izquierdo yo lo voy a poner el lado
derecho y la derivada con respecto a x
ojo estoy poniendo lo mismo para que se
mantengan la igualdad la derivada con
respecto de x de 100 bueno como la
derivada es un operador lineal entonces
esto es lo mismo que la derivada con
respecto a x del primer sumando que es x
cuadrado más la derivada con respecto a
x del segundo sumando que es la derivada
con respecto a x de ye cuadrada y esto
es igual a la derivada con respecto a x
de 100 pero la derivada con respecto a x
de 100 pues la derivada una constante es
decir se va cuál es el cambio con
respecto a x de 100 pues no hay ningún
cambio eso se mantiene constante por lo
tanto es cero
la derivada con respecto a x de una
constante es 0 y bueno ahora vamos a ver
qué pasa con el lado izquierdo de esta
igualdad la derivada con respecto a xx
cuadrada pues ya lo habíamos hecho acá
arriba la derivada con respecto a x de
ex cuadrada es ni más ni menos que 2 x
entonces vamos a ponerlo esto es 2 x más
la derivada con respecto a x de ye
cuadrada aquí es donde tal vez se
confundan un poco y esto lo que vamos a
ver con mucha calma bueno entonces para
hacer esta derivada que tenemos aquí con
respecto a x de cuadrada voy a hacer
voy a llamarla como una función y voy a
intentar resolverla desde ahí voy a
decir que la función g va a ser igual a
cuadrada y desde ahí va a salir van a
ver que no está tan difícil
solamente pónganme mucha atención
entonces sea la función e igual al
cuadrado a la función que tenemos aquí
muy bien entonces voy a utilizar la
misma idea que hemos estado usando si yo
aplicó el operador derivada con respecto
a x de ambos lados entonces se mantiene
una igualdad entonces vamos a hacerlo la
derivada con respecto a x
es igual a pues la derivada con respecto
a x de cuadrada porque genera igual a ye
cuadrada muy bien ahora me voy a fijar
en la primera parte dice la derivada con
respecto a x deje la derivada de g con
respecto a x es igual a la derivada con
respecto a x de de cuadrada aquí no hice
mucho más que poner de una manera un
poco más amena porque en este momento
voy a utilizar la regla de la cadena
para hacer la parte izquierda de esta
igualdad entonces vamos a hacerlo yo
tengo la derivada de g con respecto a x
quien va a ser igual esto bueno por la
regla de la cadena esto es igual a la
derivada de g con respecto al que voy a
insertar una variable la variable y por
la derivada de con respecto a x y si no
tienes mucha idea o mucha intuición de
lo que es la regla de la cadena tú lo
puedes visualizar de esta forma tú sabes
que deje de x a lo largo de todo lo que
hemos visto acerca del cálculo integral
y el cálculo diferencial son medidas muy
pero muy pero muy pequeñas realmente
realmente
muy pequeñas por lo tanto si yo veo un
cambio muy muy pequeño en y un cambio
muy pequeño en abajo entonces se pueden
cancelar estos dos como si fueran
fracciones esto es lo que pasa cuando
tienes cambios muy pequeños por lo tanto
se cumple la regla de la cadena así que
con esta idea de la regla de la cadena
vamos a poder resolver el ejercicio de
una manera muy sencilla la voy a
encerrar para que nos sirva de más
adelante porque que dice dice la
derivada de g con respecto a x es igual
a la derivada de g con respecto a iu y
bueno esperen que nada pues que era
igual al 10 cuadrada entonces lo voy a
volver a anotar aquí para que no se nos
olvide que es igual y encuadrada y ahora
sí cuál es la derivada de g con respecto
a y pues esto es bajamos el exponente y
me queda 2 bien ya hemos visto muchas
veces la derivada de que cuadrada es
igual a 210 lo derivamos con respecto a
y bajamos el exponente ponemos la
variable normal y le bajamos con el
exponente ya esto hay que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de ella con respecto a x
que de hecho es lo que nosotros queremos
despejar lo que nosotros queremos es
saber cuánto vale
derivada de 10 con respecto a equis y
bueno todo esto ya me dio por fin la
derivada de que con respecto a x pero
quién era g que es igual al cuadrado lo
tengo aquí por lo tanto esta derivada
con respecto x es lo mismo que la
derivada que acabamos de sacar solamente
me falta sustituir todo lo que fue la
derivada de que con respecto a x
entonces pues vamos a hacerlo voy a
tener que poner la derivada de ye
cuadrada con respecto x es lo mismo que
dos veces bien por la derivada de y con
respecto a x la derivada de y con
respecto a x y esto es igual a 0 y bueno
lo que sí quiero que veamos que no
siempre tienen que hacer todas estas
cuentas para resolver este tipo de
ejercicios ustedes lo pueden hacer una
manera más rápida decir la derivada de
cuadrada con respecto ayer es igualdad
[ __ ] y después a esto lo multiplicó por
la derivada de y con respecto a x todo
esto por la regla de la cadena si se
dieron cuenta la regla de la cadena no
era un [ __ ] extraño siempre
sencillamente era una multiplicación de
fracciones entonces si tú quieres usar
una idea más rápida y más monótona de
cómo resolver estos ejercicios lo puedes
hacer
a hacer todas estas cuentas que tenemos
aquí bueno de hecho ya no tengo espacio
entonces voy a borrar y yo creo que esto
de aquí y voy a borrar también estoy acá
ya no me sirve y voy a borrar esto de
aquí para terminar en un ejercicio y
ahora bien para terminar este problema
lo que necesitamos es despejar a la
derivada de llegó en respecto a x por lo
tanto lo que mostraba es el 2x lo voy a
pasar del otro lado con signo contrario
entonces me queda 2 por la derivada de
ye con respecto a x es igual y éste lo
paso del otro lado me queda 2x y ahora
si yo paso dividiendo el 2 ya me va a
quedar que la derivada de que con
respecto a x es igual a menos 2 x entre
2 ya pero el 2 cuando se vale me quedan
menos x entre y y por fin acabe este
ejercicio ya sé cuánto vale la derivada
de que con respecto a x y antes de
proseguir quiero que veamos una cosa
esta ecuación son la que yo empecé es la
ecuación de un círculo con centro en el
origen y con radio igual a 10 y lo que
yo estoy diciendo es que la derivada de
con respecto a x es igual a menos x /
pero si nosotros recordamos nuestro
vídeo de coordenadas polares x era igual
al coste no era igual al seno y por lo
tanto la derivada de ella con respecto a
x tiene algo que ver con la tangente
pero bueno no es una clase de
coordenadas polares en lo que yo sí
quiero que veamos es qué pasó con
nuestra derivación implícita desde
cuenta que la derivada de ye con
respecto a x esta vez no solamente
depende de x depende tanto de x como de
i es decir tengo dos variables las
cuales van a hacer que cambien mi
derivada de irie con respecto de x en
cada uno de esos puntos ahora bien si yo
solamente quiero que mi derivada dependa
de x entonces lo que hay que hacer es
despejar de la ecuación original es
decir que cuadrada es igual a 100 menos
equis cuadrada y por lo tanto que es
igual a más menos la raíz cuadrada de
100 - x cuadrado y sustituyendo me va a
quedar la derivada de ella con respecto
a x que por cierto también es lo mismo
que prima muchas personas le pueden ir
prima para hacerlo mucho más ameno y más
fácil de trabajar es igual a menos x /
pero llévale más menos la raíz de 100 x
cuadrado y si se dan cuenta con este +
menos ya no en serio poner en menos de
arriba porque menos entre más es menos y
menos entre menos es más entonces no
tiene caso es como ilógico poner este
menos entonces te voy a borrar y ya por
fin hemos terminado este ejercicio ya sé
que ya prima o la derivada de ella con
respecto a x es igual a menos y entre x
si lo queremos dejar en términos de x de
iu oa x entre más menos la raíz cuadrada
de 100 menos equis cuadradas si lo que
queremos es tenerlo como función de x
pero vamos a otro ejercicio este
ejercicio tiene un gran truco por lo
tanto yo creo que les va a gustar mucho
entonces vamos a ver cuál es nuestro
siguiente ejercicio esta función que me
voy a tomar parece ser muy sencilla de
derivar sin embargo hay que tener
cuidado no es tan sencilla de derivar es
la función que igual a x elevado a la x
esta función está de manera explícita si
yo pongo por ejemplo que x vale 3 pues 3
a la 3 es lo mismo que 27 y ya está
desde un principio ya estaba despejada
y por lo tanto si x vale 3 pues lleva el
27 y se acabó
sin embargo si yo quisiera derivar esta
función no lo puedo hacer de esta manera
si yo intentara derivar esta función por
la regla del producto pues no se puede o
por la regla de la cadena tampoco se
puede entonces la idea que vamos a
seguir es pasar esta función explícita a
una forma implícita y hacer la
derivación implícita para esto me voy a
tomar el logaritmo natural porque el
organismo natural pues porque logre
natural su derivada es muy sencilla y
además me tomo el logaritmo natural para
no complicarme con otra base entonces
logaritmo natural de iu es igual el
logaritmo natural de x elevado a la x
recuerden que aplicar un operador de
ambos lados de la igualdad se mantiene
la igualdad ahora bien me voy a tomar
una propiedad de los logaritmos que dice
que el organismo de a al ave es lo mismo
que de veces el logaritmo de a el
exponente baja y terminan multiplicando
a logaritmo de a entonces utilizar esta
propiedad me queda que logaritmo natural
de james es igual a x baja el exponente
y pasa multiplicando a logaritmo natural
de x es por esta razón que utilice los
logaritmos y ahora sí utilizando este
truco voy a aplicarla
tengo que aplicar la derivada de ambos
lados de mi igualdad entonces me voy a
tomar la derivada con respecto a x de el
logaritmo natural de james y esto va a
ser igual a la derivada con respecto a x
de x x el logaritmo natural de x y vamos
a resolver la primera parte la derivada
con respecto a x el logaritmo natural de
g
esto es por la regla de la cadena no voy
a poner otra vez todo lo que vimos con
la regla de la cadena lo que decía era
derivemos el logaritmo natural de ye gon
respecto alguien sus derivadas muy
fáciles 1 entre yemen y después
multiplicarlo por la derivada de ella
con respecto a x es decir la derivada de
ella con respecto a x idem se cuenta lo
rápido que uno puede resolver este tipo
de derivadas con la regla de la cadena
simple y sencillamente derivamos la
función con respecto a iu y lo
multiplicamos por la derivada de ye gon
respecto a x ahora hay que hacer el lado
derecho de mi ecuación la derivada con
respecto a x de x logaritmo natural de x
es una multiplicación de funciones tengo
x x el logaritmo natural de x entonces
derivamos a x que es 1 y lo
multiplicamos por el logaritmo natural
de x y ahora tenemos el organismo
natural de aquí
es uno entre equis y lo multiplicamos
por la primera función que era x muy
bien ahora voy a hacer un poquito de
espacio para terminar este ejercicio
porque esto se puede reducir bastante yo
tengo que es uno entre por la derivada
de ye con respecto a x es igual a todo
esto de aquí vamos a ponerlo 1 sobre
james que multiplica a la derivada de
ella con respecto a x es igual a 1 por
el logaritmo natural de x es el
logaritmo natural de x más el segundo
sumando que es 1 / x por x es simple es
sencillamente uno ahora me queda que la
derivada de ella con respecto a x y si
yo paso del otro lado multiplicando el
ayer porque estaba dividiendo entonces
lo voy a pasar el otro lado
multiplicando me queda ya que multiplica
a logaritmo natural de x más 1 y ya está
por fin aquí tengo la derivada de ye con
respecto a x en términos de y de x si yo
lo quisiera en términos solamente de x
hay que sustituir al ayer pero ya es
igual a x elevado al x entonces vamos a
sustituir la derivada de ayer con
respecto a x es igual a x elevado al x
por el logaritmo natural de x más
y terminando este ejercicio yo podría
decir que ya prima o sea la derivada de
ella con respecto x es igual a xl x que
ayer no voy a distribuir es x a la x que
multiplica a logaritmo natural de x más
x a la x y con esto termino esta
pantalla de ejercicio porque ya tengo la
derivada de ella con respecto a x en
términos de x es decir que prima es la
derivada de ya con respecto a x o la
pendiente de la recta tangente en
cualquier punto es una función de x y
bueno como he hablado mucho en este
vídeo me despido y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo